[Musique]
vitrine vélo maillot rambouillet est aux
couleurs du tour de france dimanche 28
juillet la grande boucle fait escale
dans la cité royale à l'occasion du
départ de la dernière étape vers paris
une première depuis juillet 2012
ce que du bonheur c'est l'aboutissement
de huit mois de travail pour
mais l'équipe high tone naturellement et
puis un une centaine de vins de
centaines de bénévoles
effectivement c'est du bonheur parce que
on va enfin vivre cette journée à
rambouillet tant attendu pour les rambos
littamé pour le territoire et pour
beaucoup de visiteurs
naturellement le rendez vous a attiré
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
spectateurs sur cette journée
l'occasion pour ces aficionados du vélo
d'approcher les coureurs qui les ont
fait vibrer cette année on habite en
région centre
on a pas d'étapes côté jean d'accord
donc on est obligé de faire deux heures
de route pour venir les voir
j'espère rencontrer beaucoup de coureurs
que j'aime bien que je voudrais d'avoir
devant moi parce que à la télé c'est
bien d'y voir biais des vents de 100
corps mieux celui que tout le monde veut
voir c'est lui et gagnent pernal à 22
ans le coureur colombien est presque
assuré de remporter le tour de france
avant le départ à rambouillet il doit
juste terminer l'étape
un résultat qui enthousiasme les
milliers de supporters colombien présent
dans les yvelines
[Applaudissements]
je suis très très heureux c'est l'un des
plus grand jour de ma vie c'est une joie
très grande c'est la première fois qu'un
sportif colombien remporte le tour de
france c'est quelque chose de très
important et nous sommes fiers de
représenter notre drapeau et notre pays
une fois les signatures et laissez-les
fit terminer direction la ligne de
départ pour les spectateurs pour voir le
départ de la caravane et de ses 160
véhicules décorés aux couleurs des
marques
elle les coureurs s'élancent ensuite à
18h10 depuis le parc du château de
rambouillet et en direction de paris
les yvelinois reverront le tour de
france l'année prochaine
une convention a été signée par le
département pour accueillir la dernière
étape de la grande boucle jusqu'en 2023
[Musique]